why exactly light slowing down would
imply that it bends as it enters a
medium if you have some light wave
shining into a material like glass if it
slows down notice how that means that it
gets kind of scrunched up if its
wavelength in a vacuum was some number
Lambda then the wavelength inside this
material where it's gotten slowed down
is something smaller than that this
particular animation is a little bit
messy and hard to follow so it might be
clearer if instead we simply color every
point of the plane such that those
points are white near the crests of the
wave and then black away from the crests
if that glass were positioned at an
angle think about what happens to each
one of those wave crests as it hits the
glass the lower parts slow down before
the top Parts causing it to get sort of
smeared out and overall the wave Crest
ends up at a different angle when you
take into account the fact that for a
beam of light the beam is always
perpendicular to those wave crests this
means your light has to turn and
moreover you can calculate exact